yeah we're talking first we feast I'm
Sean Evans and you're watching hot ones
the show with hot questions and even
hotter wings it's a very special episode
for a number of reasons first it looks
like we finally spent a couple bucks on
production Thank You number two we're on
the road for the first time ever here in
LA and I'm joined by Tommy Chong it's so
good to catch up with you I like when we
catch up because you always have really
cool things to show me no thank you now
chums choice man I got a whole line of
flour and oil that we're going to unveil
February the 6th in San Bernardino at
the Cannabis Cup all right you know how
the show works yes are you ready I'm
ready
all right this first sauce is just
sriracha it is like a diner staple it's
on every table I use it open deal you
know sriracha good if you had to drop
acid at Coachella with either Bill
O'Reilly Nancy Grace Sean Hannity no you
don't have to talk to her
Bill O'Reilly insulted me and tried to
ESA's and we were on you know and I
asked him at the end of the show I said
have you ever smoked weed and built of
course not
never remember eyes well that's why
you're so angry any
literally said I'm not angry who said I
was angry all right this next one is
Tapatio good wing where when you were
performing with Bobby Taylor in the
Vancouver mm-hmm and you were in Chicago
and you saw Michael Jackson in the
Jackson 5 we need 8 years old
did you see a star in the making what do
you remember about that night I remember
this little guy while we met him in the
dressing room first he's so cute he
comes on and it had a little little
coca-cola carton and he put it on head
and stood on it
the club was here in the beer little
nappy hair you comb it away but he went
on stage and he sang like Marvin Gaye
even he killed and it was Bobby Taylor
that that said hey these these kids are
gonna make it
he took him to contrite put him up in
his apartment which my daughter radon
was staying there at the same time so I
can safely say that my daughter slept
with Michael Jackson this next one
oh you could techno Caribbean habanero
huh a little bit see that's the thing me
when you work ahead you get a little
cocky even hot ones that can catch up to
you you're the victim of a death hoax
last month you know what goes through
your mind when the entire internet
thinks you're dead and they're all
eulogizing you online was the second
time I've been through it before I asked
my wife my dad he goes now close to it
but not really so long as she says I'm
alive dating okay all right number four
is holy Shh yes that's hot whoo what is
and that's only for this is High River
hellacious hot sauce yeah you gotta be
careful out here a few many years go
away for going in I love these wings
[Music]
from Jimmy Hendrix to Bob Marley Snoop
Dogg and everyone in between who's your
most fun famous friend smoke weed with I
smoke in the same apartment with Jimmy
Hendrix
but Jimmy was in the bathroom but long
period of time doing his junk
you know his drug of choice right which
was heroin I did I used to do a
limitation that me smoking with Jimi
Hendrix and I'll get it he's on the
floor oh and then I just do it with
Kareem abdul-jabbar movies yeah you know
I'll tell you what Snoop Dogg he Bogart
to joint he has a passive he doesn't
pass it he talks to you and it burns and
he does good louisiana-style
that's a kid screaming looks like it Sam
Kinison do you want to stand up her team
hmm Sam Kinison doing stand-up yep do
you ever see him
yeah I've seen your insane Tommy this is
this is the move of a psycho well it's a
little bit Lucy okay the other ones like
[__]
hmm
[Music]
our target hmm so that's a two-burner
and you were at Taft you're bunked up
with Jordan Belfort did he ever tell you
a story some sort of wild story he he'd
once owned the largest yacht in the
world right that yacht was so big it had
a 40 foot yacht on the back of it and a
helicopter in the front of it and one
time Amon is wiping a friend and their
wife his way we're flying to they were
going to go to Sardinia halfway across
the Mediterranean a freak storm happened
I remember that scene a freak storm and
never happened before and Jordan Belfort
the boats going down with a 40-footer
and the helicopter and everything else
and Air Rescue are over over top with
the helicopter to run a rescue and so
Jordan and his buddy Elbert all there
are things that they should rescue the
only rescued one thing which was a jar
of quaaludes all right so this next one
hi River rogue I understand that you
were originally pegged you're nuts
I understand that you're originally
pegged as one of the hyenas and The Lion
King daddy be careful you're insane
Tommy you're wild so you're a peg to be
one of the hyenas and you turned it down
end up given the role of Whoopi Goldberg
you regret turning it down that I've
been kind of cool if your other hyenas
I don't mean readout of the time because
Disney was so straight you know they
didn't want dope in my blah blah blah
you know and once got kicked out of
Disneyland because I was wearing a
obscene t-shirt so I wasn't a big Disney
fan alright so I want to give you a line
from the movie because I always wonder
like with Tommy Chong have read it as
Tommy Chong or what do you have done
some sort of crazy hyena cartoon voice
so let me give you the line and you can
tell me how you would have delivered it
look at you guys
no wonder we're dangling at the bottom
of the food chain if it weren't for
those Lions we'd be running the joint
well I would have probably look at you
guys and no wonder you're dangling at
the bottom of the food chain if we work
for these lands we'd be running the
joint
I regret that you didn't take back power
I met the kid that rode all that okay
really and he was very sad that you
didn't take it yeah he said he was
having a party spending he was up nights
working on it and then I turned it down
yeah I'm actually gonna be in a new
Disney movie you are yes doing voiceover
yeah Duke boy so when I play a character
it's a major
animation that you called Zootopia
Zootopia so you play an animal now that
you didn't get that hyena part I guess
it's like a water buffalo
Tommy's in water but it would flies all
around me an earthy it's a funny movie
because I'll I belong to a nudist colony
for poor animals
it's very funny all the other animals
are addressed
they all wear pants and stuff after they
all repair and they get all disgusted at
the naked ones it's really good around
8:00 to bomb hot sauce oh this was so
hot I feel like teeth that one sucks the
bomb sucks they also suck from here on
out I saw you can't pay me in for Bernie
why do you think that he'd make a good
commander and cush as you put it well
because he doesn't have to think when
people asking questions you know he had
he doesn't have to spend a lot of time
thinking what would be the the best
thing to say at the time bernie is from
the heart and it would be nice to get a
leg off Jimmy Carter back only not not
the yep he evangelist Jimmy Carter but
but a Jewish Jimmy Carter number 9 now
this is mad dog 357 see someone owes our
hottest sauce now it's our second hot
sauce who's our Crazy Heart
but once you get going you can't start
it's good addicted to it
oh but you know what really helped me
eat all this is the chunks choice this
chunk choice man gives you an appetite
and it gives you immunity against all
the hot sauce yeah that's that's
possible your eyeballs start sweating
that's not I saw you on cannabis club TV
this promo and it was cooking with Tommy
Chong don't remember shooting this which
one cooking you're cooking you never
really got to it it's sort of like a
promo Oh everyone knows about brownies
and everyone knows about cookies I'm
wonder if you're on Top Chef stoners
what would be your signature dish like
what would you present to the judges to
impress them myself I do up linguine and
clam dish color it's too fattening to do
all the time but I use a wok and they
put the clams in there and I
with garlic ginger very Chinese and kind
of thing and then when that's cooking
real good I throw in the noodles well
I'm gonna let like an oil or something
how do you get like the oils get the oil
that's my signature dish I can't refuse
it
good all right last wing one more oh I
gotta throw this one away there's a
little bit of sausage oh wait number 10
have you smoked weed important no never
my life well I was a virgin till I was
17 that was kind of that I read that and
that was kind of that same kind of later
to me for you that's he kind of late in
the ball game
well technically fooling around mend
anything I was there you know
technically you know where you do the
hole where you put a dude are we talking
about I never put it in until I was 17
are we still talking about we know we're
talking about being a virgin okay so
we're talking about sex now yeah okay I
just want to make sure all right you did
a phenomenal reddit AMA recently I loved
it and he told this crazy story about
this acid trip and you went to go see
Thumbelina matinee showing of Thumbelina
and I was dying picturing that with I
think I've looked at one part where some
ballina was supposed to marry a rat and
the theater was like you know in in a
black neighborhood and so all these
little kids that were running around
they weren't watching the movie they're
just there to run up and
even when I was on acid I felt like
there were rats running up and down the
aisle and it just scared the Dickens out
of me and to my little four-year-old
she's sitting there with just just into
the moon and my wife and every thing in
do we do it let's get out of here well
it's easy to fly off the rails they're
stickers but I didn't do it come on mmm
these are good wings
I wonder tell me about a time in your
life where you thought to yourself
whoa maybe I should have smoked all that
weed um no I've never had time in my
life like that
whoa yes right yeah right there was one
time I was at a Snoop Dogg and be real
concert in Cypress Hill Inn in LA I
think was the last one they had was held
in LA and be real brought up the 6-foot
ball on stage and challenged me to smoke
out of it
and I not only smoked out her but for
some reason I thought I really had to
take a real strong totally you cleared
the chamber and I cleared the chamber
and the crowd went crazy and once the
crowd goes crazy in there
showing crazy too much after that that
smoke just went in every pore of my body
was coming up my eyeballs it was oh it
was the biggest toke I ever done but
you'll do things in front of a crowd you
wouldn't do everything I like the idea
of you just hotdog and after you clear
the chamber on the six-foot-long and
then being like how to be carried so I'm
calling it I'm throwing in the towel
you'll be sitting there's over you'd be
sitting there going come on are you
screw you but yes exactly 30 seconds the
floor is your person oh I guess 30
seconds okay 30 seconds February 6 San
Bernadino California cannabis cup that's
how you got to remember it be there
because I'm gonna have a booth and I'm
gonna be selling my flower qiong's
choice along with these what are these
breath mints yeah like profits yeah like
a breath mint that that's a little
weaker but still will get you there and
we got the oil and we got chunk choice
blend yeah that's it I could do that
another 12 are you just I feel like
you're bumping in my face now me I feel
like you're showing I'm serious that I
told you I got an operation there's part
of me that doesn't have to worry about
it anymore